tonight the world is mourning the loss
of one of the most influential people in
history the Reverend Billy Graham died
at his North Carolina home this morning
he was 99 during most of those years
Graham's spread the gospel to hundreds
of millions of people in person in
almost 200 countries he was a pastor to
the world and a pastor to presidents
President Trump tweeted today the great
Billy Graham is dead
there was nobody like him he will be
missed by Christians and all religions a
very special man jesus said there too
rose there's the broad road that leads
to destruction and judgment and this the
other road that leads to heaven fitting
for a man who touched hundreds of
millions with his message of hope and
faith and followed Jesus let him lead
you home the outpouring of condolences
for the passing of evangelist Billy
Graham has been just as heartfelt even
as we remember Reverend Graham this
morning and keep his family in our
hearts we continue this renewed work
Graham preached to more people than
anyone in world history
Christianity is not a white man's
religion and don't let anybody ever tell
you that it's white a black Christ
belongs to a man of God humbled by the
fellowship that shaped and embraced him
called by some the Protestant Pope the
world was his pulpit the Reverend Billy
Graham said he first felt the spirit at
age 16 after hearing an evangelist
preach soon after leaving his family's
dairy farm for Bible College in Florida
where he started preaching on the
streets of Tampa I have a place there
where the saloonkeeper threw me out into
a ditch
and told me never to come back grande
received a warmer reception from Ruth
Bell the two married in 1943 and as
their family grew so did his ministry a
1949 California tent revival drew
national attention Israel did not obey
the voice of God it's real wondered
further and further from God
around the world crowds began filling
stadiums coming to hear a spirited new
message about Jesus Christ and his
Heavenly Father I want to tell you about
God Graham became a confidant of
presidents and offered spiritual
guidance at seven inaugurations shall we
pray although he was asked many times to
run for office Graham said he was never
tempted he just wanted to preach which
he did into his 80s I have no plans to
retire the Lord may have plans but
Parkinson's disease slowed him down I
think God has sent it to me at this age
to show me that I'm totally dependent on
him
his ministry has been passed on to his
daughter Ann and son Franklin who spoke
with us during the 2016 election about
his father's impact what would your dad
say about the current state of affairs
politically in the country
my father's not only sad I think he's
and discouraged is probably a better
where he's just discouraged when he sees
how far we have fallen so quickly and
how quickly our nation and our
politicians what started in a tent so
many decades ago has turned into the
largest ministry in world history
a multimedia innovator into the digital
age Billy Graham's legacy lives on
with a simple enduring message but if
you remember nothing that I say tonight
except one thing I want you to remember
Billy Graham 99 years old